[Music]
at the summit of the americas u.s
president joe biden has focused in part
on global warming and clean energy
through our efforts to strengthen clean
energy economy in the americas we're
committing to just not just energy
transition but to make communities that
have been historically marginalized are
able to share equally in the gains
the u.s unveiled a plan to cooperate and
help fund caribbean countries trying to
strengthen their vulnerable
infrastructure
in the face of rising sea levels and
more frequent and destructive storms and
to move away from fossil fuel
our member states
are heavily dependent on fossil fuels
for our energy needs another program
sets goals for boosting the region's
clean renewable energy sources for
electricity major economies like
argentina and brazil have signed on
the president of paraguay spoke for many
countries in latin america and the
caribbean saying they are suffering from
a climate crisis they didn't help to
create
greenhouse gas emissions in paraguay are
low however we have suffered greatly and
we have suffered the effects over the
last few years this is seen in droughts
floods fires and crises when it comes to
our water resources we need specific
commitments especially from the
countries who bear the most
responsibility
biden is also pushing an initiative
aimed at saving what's left of the
amazon rainforest that could lead to
awkward moments during his first
one-on-one meeting with brazilian
president jair bolsonaro who has
encouraged more economic development in
brazil's amazon basin
as with any gathering of the powerful
protesters also came a protester
demanding protection of abortion rights
in the u.s stepped in front of biden's
motorcade and was tackled by two secret
service agents and taken into custody
migrants rights advocates demonstrated
with a message for biden we promise
solutions we demand that those solutions
come forward what happens when you have
politicians and executives in a room is
often that the people that are most
directly impacted by their decisions are
left out
the number of migrants seeking to enter
the u.s as well as countries like
colombia and chile has reached
record-setting levels this year on
friday the summit participants will sign
a declaration on migration but no
comprehensive solution to the vast and
complex problem is anticipated
migration is a thorny issue and dealing
with it is made even more difficult by
the number of empty seats at the table
here the leaders of guatemala honduras
mexico and other countries that are the
homelands of many migrants have
boycotted this summit rob reynolds al
jazeera los angeles